let's talk about this elephant in the
brain
uh amazing book
the elephant in the room
is quote an important issue that people
are reluctant to acknowledge or address
a social taboo the elephant in the brain
is an important but unacknowledged
feature of how our mind works
and introspective taboo
you describe
selfishness and self-deception
as uh
the core or some of the core elephants
some of the elephants elephant offspring
in the brain
selfishness and self-deception
all right
can you explain can you explain why
these are um the taboos in our brain
that we
uh
don't want to acknowledge your conscious
mind the one that's listening to me that
i'm talking to at the moment allegedly
you like to think of yourself as the
president or king of your mind
ruling over all that you see issuing
commands that immediately obeyed yes
you are instead better understood as the
press secretary of your brain
you don't make decisions you justify
them to an audience
that's what your conscious mind is for
you watch what you're doing
and you try to come up with stories that
explain what you're doing so that you
can avoid accusations of violating norms
so
humans compared to most other animals
have norms and this allows us to manage
larger groups with our morals and norms
about what we should or shouldn't be
doing this is so important to us that we
needed to be constantly watching what we
were doing in order to make sure we had
a good story to avoid norm violation so
many norms are about motives so if i hit
you on purpose that's a big violation of
hit you accidentally that's okay
i need to be able to explain why it was
an accident and not on purpose
uh so where does that need come from for
your own self-preservation right so
humans have norms and we have the norm
that if we see anybody violating a norm
we need to tell other people and then
coordinate to to just make them stop and
punish them for for violating so
such benefits are strong enough and
severe enough that we each want to avoid
being successfully accused of violating
norms
so for example hitting someone on
purpose is a big clear norm violation if
we do it consistently we may be thrown
out of the group and that would mean we
would die that's right okay so we need
to be able to convince people we are not
going around hitting people on purpose
if somebody happens to be at the other
end of our fist and their face connects
that was an accident and we need to be
able to explain that
and similarly for many other norms
humans have uh we are serious about
these norms and we don't want people to
violate we find them violating we're
going to accuse them but many norms have
a motive component and so we are trying
to explain ourselves and make sure we
have a good motive story about
everything we do
which is why we're constantly
trying to explain what we're doing and
that's what your conscious mind is doing
it is trying to make sure you've got a
good motive story for everything you're
doing and that's why you don't know why
you really do things what you know is
what the good story is about why you've
been doing things and that's the
self-deception and you're saying that
there is a machine the actual dictator
is selfish
and then you're just the press secretary
who's desperately doesn't want to get
fired and is justifying all of all the
decisions of the dictator and that's the
self-deception
right now most people actually are
willing to believe that this is true in
the abstract so our book has been
classified as psychology and it was
reviewed by psychologists and the basic
way that psychology referees and
reviewers responded to say this is well
known
most people accept that there's a fair
bit of self-deception but they don't
want to accept it about themselves
directly they don't want to accept it
about the particular topics that we talk
about so people accept the idea in the
abstract that they might be
self-deceived or that they might not be
honest about various things
but that hasn't penetrated into the
literatures where people are explaining
particular things like why we go to
school why we go to the doctor why we
vote etc so our book is mainly about 10
areas of life and explaining about in
each area what our actual motives there
are
and you know people who study those
things have not admitted that hidden
motives are explaining those particular
areas they haven't taken the leap from
theoretical psychology to actual public
policy exactly and economics and all
that kind of stuff let me just linger on
this
uh and uh
bring up my
old friends uh zingman freud and carl
jung so how vast is this
uh
landscape of the unconscious mind
the power and the scope of the dictator
is it only dark there
is it uh some light is there some love
the vast majority of what's happening in
your head you are unaware of so in a
literal sense the
unconscious the
aspects of your mind that you're not
conscious of is the overwhelming
majority but but that's just true in a
literal engineering sense your mind is
doing lots of low-level things and you
just can't be consciously aware of all
that low-level stuff but there's plenty
of room there for lots of things you're
not aware of
but can we try to shine a light at the
things we're unaware of
specifically now again staying with the
philosophical psychology side for a
moment
you know can you shine the light in the
jungian shadow can you
what what's going on there what is this
machine like like what
what level of thoughts are happening
there is it uh something that could we
can even interpret if we somehow could
visualize it is it something that's
human interpretable or is it just a kind
of chaos of like monitoring different
systems in the body making sure you're
happy making sure you're um fed all
those kind of basic forces that form
abstractions on top of each other and
they're not introspective at all we
humans are social creatures plausibly
being social is the main reason we have
these unusually large brains therefore
most of our brain is devoted to being
social
and so the things we're very obsessed
with and constantly paying attention to
are
how do i look to others
what would others think of me if they
knew these various things they might
learn about me so that's close to being
fundamental to what it means to be human
is caring what others think right to to
be
trying to present a story that would be
okay for what other things but we're
very constantly thinking what do other
people think so let me ask you this
question then about you robin hansen who
many places
sometimes for fun sometimes as a basic
statement of principle
likes to disagree with with
what the majority of people think
um
so how do you explain um
how are you self-deceiving yourself in
this task
and how are you being self how's your
like why is the dictator manipulating
you inside your head to be so critical
like there's norms why do you want to
stand out
in this way why do you want to challenge
the norms in this way almost by
definition i can't tell you what i'm
deceiving myself about
but the more practical strategy that's
quite feasible is to ask about what are
typical things that most people decease
themselves about and then to own up to
those particular things sure what's
what's that what's a good one so for
example
i can very much acknowledge that i would
like to be well thought of
yes that i would be seeking uh attention
and glory and uh praise yes from my
intellectual work and that that would be
a major agenda driving my
intellectual attempts
um
so you know if there were topics that
other people would find less interesting
i might be less interested in those for
that reason for example i might want to
find topics whether people are
interested and i might want to
um go for the glory of finding a big
insight rather than a small one
and maybe one that was especially
surprising
that's also of course consistent with
some more ideal concept of what an
intellectual should be
but most intellectuals are relatively
risk-averse they are
in some local intellectual tradition and
they are adding to that and they are
staying conforming to the sort of usual
assumptions and usual accepted beliefs
and practices of a particular area
so that they can be accepted in that
area and you know treated as part of the
community
but you might think
for the purpose of the larger
intellectual project of understanding
the world better
people should be less eager to just add
a little bit to some tradition and they
should be looking for what's neglected
between the major traditions and major
questions they should be looking for
assumptions maybe we're making that are
wrong they should be looking at ways
things that are very surprising like
things that would be
you would have thought a priori unlikely
that once you are convinced of it you
find that to be very important and
a big update right so
um
you could say that um
one motivation i might have is less
motivated to be sort of comfortably
accepted into some particular
intellectual community and more willing
to just go for these
more fundamental
long shots that should be
very important if you could find them
which would if so if you can find them
would get you
appreciated uh respect across a larger
number of people across the longer time
span of history right so like maybe the
the small local community will say you
suck
right you must conform but the larger
community will see the brilliance of you
breaking out of the cage of the small
conformity into a larger cage
it's always a bigger there's always a
bigger page and then you'll be
remembered by more
yeah um also that explains your choice
of colorful shirt that looks great in a
black background so you definitely
stand out right are now of course you
know you could say well you could get
all this attention by making false
claims of dramatic improvement sure and
then wouldn't that be much easier than
actually working through all the details
why not to make true claims let me ask
the press secretary why not
why
so of course you spoke several times
about how much you value truth and the
pursuit of truth
that's a very nice narrative right
hitler and stalin also talked about the
value of truth do you worry when you
introspect as
broadly as all humans
might that it becomes a drug
this
uh
being a martyr
point being the person who points out
that the emperor wears no clothes
even when the emperor is obviously
dressed
just to be the person who points out
that the emperor is wearing no clothes
do you think about that
so
i think the
standards you hold yourself to
are dependent on the audience you have
in
mind so if you think of your audience as
relatively easily fooled
or relatively gullible
then you won't bother to generate more
complicated deep
you know
arguments and structures and evidence to
persuade somebody who has higher
standards because why bother
you you can get away with something much
easier and of course if you are say a
sales person uh you know you make money
on sales then you don't need to convince
the top few percent of the most sharp
customers you can just go for the
bottom 60 of the most gullible customers
and make plenty of sales right
so
i think um intellectuals have to vary
one of the main ways intellectuals
varies in who is their audience in their
mind who are they trying to impress
is it the people down the hall is it the
people who are reading their twitter
feed is it their parents is it their
high school teacher
right or is it einstein and freud
and socrates right
so i think
those of us who are especially arrogant
especially
think that we're really big shot or have
a chance at being a really big shot we
were naturally going to pick the
big shot audience that we can we're
going to be in trying to impress
socrates in einstein is that why you're
hanging out with tyler conan and try
sure i mean try to convince him right
you know and you might think you know
from the point of view of just making
money or having sex or other sorts of
things this is misdirected energy
right right trying to impress the very
most
highest quality minds that's such a
small sample and they can't do that much
for you anyway yeah so i might well have
had more you know ordinary success in
life be more popular invited to more
priorities make more money if i had
targeted a
lower tier
set of intellectuals with the standards
they have
but for some reason i decided early on
that einstein was my audience or people
like him
and i was gonna impress them
yeah i mean you you pick your set of
motivations uh you know convincing and
pressing tyler cohen is not gonna help
you get laid trust me i tried all right
uh
what are some notable
um
sort of effects of the elephant in the
brain in everyday life so you mentioned
when we try to apply that to economics
to public policy so when you think about
medicine education all those kinds of
things so what are some things that well
the key thing is medicine is much less
useful health-wise than you think
so you know if you're focused on your
health you would
care a lot less about it and if you were
focused on other people's health you
would also care a lot less about it but
if medicine is as we suggest more about
showing that you care and let other
people showing that they care about you
then
a lot of priority on medicine can make
sense so that was our very earliest
discussion in the podcast you were
talking about what you know should you
give people a lot of medicine when it's
not very effective and then the answer
then is well if that's the way that you
show that you care about them and you
really want them to know you care
then maybe that's what you need to do if
you can't find a cheaper more effective
substitute so if we actually just pause
on that for a little bit
how do we start
to untangle the full set of
self-deception happening in the space of
medicine
so we have a method that we use in our
book that is what i recommend for people
to use and all these sorts of topics the
straightforward method is first don't
look at yourself
look at other people
look at broad patterns of behavior in
other people and then ask
what are the various theories we could
have to explain these patterns of
behavior and then just do the simple
matching which theory better matches the
behavior they have
and the last step is to assume that's
true of youtube
don't assume you're an exception it may
if you happen to be an exception that
won't go so well but nevertheless on
average you aren't very well positioned
to judge if you're an exception so look
at what other people do explain what
other people do and assume that's
youtube but also in the case of medicine
there's several
parties to consider so there's the
individual person that's receiving the
medicine there's the doctors that are
prescribing the medicine
there is um
drug companies that are selling drugs
there are governments that have
regulations that are lobbyists so you
can build up a network of
categories of humans in this
and they each play their role
so how do you introspect
the
sort of analyze the system at a system
scale versus at the individual scale
so it turns out that in general it's
usually much easier to explain producer
behavior than consumer behavior that is
the drug companies or the doctors
have relatively clear incentives to give
the customers whatever they want yeah
and similarly say governments and
democratic countries have the incentive
to give the voters what they want so
uh that focuses your attention on the
patient and the voter
in this equation and saying what do they
want they would be driving the rest of
the system
whatever they want the other parties are
willing to give them
in order to get paid
so now we're looking for puzzles in
patient and voter behavior what are they
choosing and why do they choose that
and how much exactly and then we can
explain that potentially again returning
to the producer but the producer being
incentivized to manipulate the
decision-making processes of the voter
and the consumer now in almost every
industry producers are in general happy
to lie
and exaggerate in order to get more
customers this is true of auto repair as
much as human body repair and medicine
so the differences between these
industries can't be explained by the
willingness of the producers to give
customers what they want or to do
various things that we have to again
go to the customers why are customers
treating body repair different than auto
repair
yeah and that potentially requires a lot
a lot of thinking a lot of data
collection and potentially looking at
historical data too because things don't
just happen overnight that over time
there's principle it does but actually
it's a lot actually easier than you
might think
i think the biggest limitation is just
the willingness to consider alternative
hypotheses so many of the patterns that
you need to rely on are actually pretty
obvious simple patterns you just have to
notice them and ask yourself how can i
explain those
often you don't need to look at the most
subtle most you know difficult
statistical evidence that might be out
there the simplest patterns are often
enough
all right so there's a fundamental
statement about self-deception in the
book there's the application of that
like we just did in medicine
can you steal man
the argument that
uh
many of the foundational ideas in the
book are wrong
meaning uh
there's two that you just made which is
it can be a lot simpler than it looks
can you steal man in the case that it's
case by case it's go it's always super
complicated like it's a complex system
that's very difficult to have a simple
model about it's very difficult to
disrespect and the other one is that the
human brain isn't
not just about self-deception
that that there's a lot of there's a lot
of motivation to play and we are able to
really introspect our own mind and like
what what's on the surface of the
conscious is actually quite a good
representation of what's going on in the
brain and you're not deceiving yourself
you're able to actually arrive
to deeply think about where your mind
stands and what you think about the
world and it's less about impressing
people and more about being a
free-thinking individual
so
when a
child um tries to explain why they don't
have their homework assignment yes they
are sometimes inclined to say the dog
ate my homework they almost never say
the dragon ate my homework
the reason is the dragon is a completely
implausible explanation
almost always when we make excuses for
things we choose things that are at
least in some degree plausible it could
perhaps have happened
that's an obstacle
for any explanation of a hidden motive
or a hidden feature of human behavior if
people are pretending one thing while
really doing another they're usually
going to pick as a pretense something
that's somewhat plausible
that's going to be an obstacle to
proving that hypothesis
if you are focused on sort of the local
data that a person would typically have
if they were challenged so if you're
just looking at one kid and his lack of
homework yeah
maybe you can't tell whether his dog ate
his homework or not if you happen to
know he doesn't have a dog
you might have more confidence right you
will need to have a wider range of
evidence than a typical person would
when they're encountering that actual
excuse in order to see past the excuse
that will just be a general feature of
this so in order if i say you know
there's a usual story about where we go
to the doctor and then there's this
other explanation you know it'll be true
that you'll have to look at wider data
in order to see that because
you know people don't usually offer
excuses unless in the local context of
their excuse they can get away with it
that is it's hard to tell right
so in the case of medicine i have to
point you to sort of larger sets of data
but in many areas of academia including
health economics
the researchers there also
want to support the usual points of view
and so they will
have selection effects in their
publications and their analysis whereby
they
if they're getting a result too much
contrary to the usual point of view
everybody wants to have they will file
draw that paper
or redo the analysis until they get an
answer that's more to people's liking
so that means in the health economics
literature there are plenty of people
who will claim that in fact we have
evidence that medicine is effective
and when i respond i will have to point
you to our most reliable evidence
and ask you to consider the possibility
that the literature is biased in that
when the when the evidence isn't as
reliable when they have more degrees of
freedom in order to get the answer they
want they do tend to get the answer they
want but
when we get to the kind of evidence
that's much harder to mess with
that's where the that's where we will
see the truth be more revealed so with
respect to medicine
we have millions of papers published in
medicine over the years most of which
give the impression that medicine is
useful
there's a small literature on randomized
experiments of the aggregate effects of
medicine where there's you know maybe a
few half dozen or so papers
where it would be the hardest to hide it
because it's such a straightforward
experiment done in a straightforward way
that um
you know it's hard to manipulate and
that's where i will point you to to show
you that there's relatively little
correlation between health medicine but
even then
people could try to save the phenomenon
and say well it's not hidden motives
it's just ignorance they could say for
example
you know medicine's complicated most
people don't know the literature
therefore
they can be excused for for ignorance
they are just ignorantly assuming that
medicine is effective it's not that they
have some other motive that they're
trying to achieve
and then i will have to do you know as
with a conspiracy theory analysis and
i'm saying well like how long has this
misperception be going on how
consistently has it happened around the
world and across time
and i would have to say look uh you know
if we're talking about say a recent new
product like segway scooters or
something
i could say not so many people have seen
them or use them maybe they could be
confused about their value if we're
talking about a product that's been
around for thousands of years used in
roughly the same way all across the
world and we see the same pattern over
and over again
this sort of
ignorance mistake just doesn't work so
well it also is a question of
how much of the self-deception
is prevalent versus foundational
because there's a kind of implied thing
where it's foundational to human nature
versus just a common pitfall
this is this is a question i have so
like maybe maybe human progress is made
by people
who don't fall into the self-deception
it's it's like it's a baser aspect of
human nature but then you escape it
easily if you if you're motivated
the motivational hypotheses about these
self-deceptions are in terms of how it
makes you look to the people around you
again the press secretary yes so the
story would be
most people want to look good to the
people around them
therefore most people present themselves
in ways that
help them look good to the people around
them
that's sufficient to say there would be
a lot of it it doesn't need to be 100
right there's enough variety in people
and in circumstances that sometimes
taking a contrary and strategy can be in
the interest of some minority of the
people
so i might for example say that that's a
strategy i've taken
i've decided that uh
being contrarian on these things could
be winning for me
in that there's a room for a small
number of people like me who have
these sort of messages who can then get
more attention even if there's not room
for most people to do that
and that can be explaining sort of the
variety right so similarly you might say
look
just look at the most obvious things
most people would like to look good
right in the sense of physically just
you look good right now you're wearing a
nice suit you have a haircut you shaved
right
so and we have my own hair but okay well
that's all the more impressive that's
the counter uh that's the counter
argument for your claim right
so clearly if you look at most people in
their physical appearance clearly most
people are trying to look somewhat nice
right they shower they they shave they
comb their hair but we certainly see
some people around who are not trying to
look so nice right is that a
big challenge the hypothesis that people
want to look nice not that much right we
can see
in the those particular people's context
more particular reasons why they've
chosen to be an exception to the more
general rule
so the general rule does reveal
something foundational
generally
you